hello everyone my name is Tamara
chambers chambers I'm Steve chambers
Cindy and this is my nan movie-watching
family and this is tamara has never seen
we will address why I haven't seen any
movies so stick around to the end today
we are watching adventures in
babysitting so you guys not seen this
film we were trying to watch what's up
girls
don't tell mother the babysitter done
guys there's something we haven't seen
that either and I couldn't find our
names on so we're watching this instead
I'm sorry but you guys all snap with
your right hands
[Music]
so we just watched adventures in
babysitting mmm it was painful it was so
bad that was painful I had to like
Corral everyone to stay in the room but
that's true so there's a dance sequence
in the beginning that was like fun that
was part of it that was like okay this
is fun it's also very long where Chris
is dancing over the beginning of but it
goes on for a long time
what's a felt dirty risky business or
business but yeah you guys multi met but
that that gave you promise I love the
movies gonna be fun that was a good
start and then it kind of diagnosed it
was cute but it was like cheesy cute
Chris is supposed to go off on her
anniversary with her boyfriend who's a
big dick and he cancels on their
anniversary because he's a big dick and
so she ends up taking a last minute
remaining sitting job really big Nick
and it takes a pretty big job and it
goes and that's the whole premise of
this shitty movie Chris shows up to
babysit these children one of them Brad
has a giant crush on her and the other
wants to be thor which is probably the
best part of the thing to carry the half
the movie yes little girl wants me Thor
girl especially not including Thor
Ragnarok is the best Thor movie I've
ever seen she's right and her brother
Brad makes fun of her for loving thorns
like Thor's a homo oh yeah he's a jerk
in what way dad also that's a compliment
shut up Brad Brad
also Brad laughs after every language
he's like oh so money's red bezoars a
homo
hey Ryan is horrendous yeah and the
acting was horrendous she's babysitting
them and she gets a call from her friend
farm I meet Barbara barb from stranger
things I know she'd be anointed this
because this came before she thinks but
it's literally agent Barton strangely
she's scared because she's in downtown
Chicago and she needs Chris who's
babysitting these children to go over at
Corinth though I said Ron Weasley's in
this and he's a dick
I really did genuinely enjoy that they
gave the little girl the trait that she
left for I thought that was really sweet
I loved that it was like wouldn't work
for her no girl wouldn't work for Brad
and dick it was nice that or the little
girl had the obsession with I thought
that was really cool it came in a couple
times through the film at the end it's
shown that Thor's gonna help them and
he's just as easy like guy Raj owner
another dick but it's really great it
does tie in nicely that was my favorite
part of the film by far is the Thor a
SPECT of it but pretty much everything
else was really flat but there's just
one really good scene in this bar okay
so a lot of things happen they see I
tired it's flat and then this guy picks
him up and is gonna change the tire and
then ends up that he's punching someone
else so they end up in this stolen car
and then they don't know send him in
this warehouse and then they sneak out
of the warehouse then they end up in his
Blues Bar in downtown Chicago and the
guy on stage because somehow they end up
on stage with this man he's like well
you can't leave the club but she didn't
seem blues and she's like she's like
freaking out that she can't sing and
then she starts singing with the most
confidence I've ever seen anyone sing
with yeah
that's just not how that works with your
hair and saying oh we also flip our hair
I maybe everyone flip I mean she was
belting it out but she was really pretty
much reflected at least there are some
really good quotes in the film like you
slipped me the cash that's the view the
Weiner yeah
thank God it's saved with the movie
finally in the end they get their car
back they speed on back home they make
it in bed right in time because it's the
Jeremy lady's film and everything's okay
for the record I won't watch right that
we couldn't watch that no one likes
right back and get some Twitter I said
adventures and babysitting predictions
and questions for my parents preferably
other than just why we didn't watch any
movies and then I put a gif of barb
yelling into the phone we're scared okay
Oh mr. and mrs. chambers do you watch
cameras stuff on YouTube well her dad
does when weird ideas tear my mother
you'll have a lily adore Sarah she's the
best hurt for sure yeah yes factory yeah
yeah yeah that was awful and she was at
least cute and exactly not believable
but like better she was better you will
a hundred percent be on board with it as
soon as you hear those first few seconds
of then he kissed me at the beginning no
[Laughter]
they demonize rats as bad pets oh yeah
remember yogurt no didn't live in a bus
stop
yogurt was my best friend sixth grade he
was a question for your parents
why did Tamra and Taylor watch
secondhand lions some member pegannon
lions we watched it so much the Blues
love scene will be slightly
uncomfortable to watch yes it was very
uncomfortable but I was pretty
comfortable question for Tamra chambers
parents who's your favorite child you'll
be glad you don't live in the scary part
of Chicago in this movie all of Chicago
is scary and only the burbs are the
safety zone you'll wonder if college
parties were really that fun you're
asking if you guys were disco skaters oh
my god you guys Amish okay I'm done now
Amish because I didn't see a lot of
movies growing yeah what a real mission
so will you guys will you guys get rid
of the myth right now where we are oh
you know we're pretty just low-key
Protestants are you guys opposed to
saying the f-word if I bleep it out
because we have to yell a patch phrase
from the film which is don't babysitter
and I'll just believe it out so we
didn't like it that's just basically I
liked it Taylor loved it I have a
question he's the black sheep of the
family
uh-huh why do you think it is because we
grew up very normal it was very normal
it wasn't because like we did you can't
see these it was just like why do you
think why do you think I didn't watch
like like like that
the future and like why do you think I
didn't see like Jurassic Park and stuff
like that well because we're just so
busy all the time really
you were busy kid you were much the
center watch as I share palace that
should be maybe person when you guys
were a little less poster no you are
absolutely you watch VHS Disney movies
man yeah right it was VHS Disney yeah we
weren't my community a lot of uh a lot
of bolts will stuff that you guys would
refer to today but just what was on him
just goodness goodness wholesome
secondly alliance exactly it wasn't even
though it was a lot of wholesome films
it it was never something where I was
like I want to see that you guys look
you can't it was just we just watched
she would ask movies right I bet it had
Netflix back yeah we probably would have
yeah well everyone is gonna say that you
lying and that sounds like a pair why
they don't like we're Amish liars
because an Amish people I all those that
we didn't watch your head I wouldn't
dispel that myth because what were they
just born last year what what some of
them yes okay well don't read the
comments everyone be nice to my parents
and thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys next week thanks so much
for watching bye perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
you